- I saw that you recently
had an eye patch.
You had to wear an eye patch.
- Yes!
- I did too!
- I saw that. Yeah, we were twinsies.
- Why did you, I kind of
felt like I was an assassin.
Like, I felt like I was this sexy assassin
like with it on, I probably
didn't look like that.
- I was like the masked pirate
because I had the mask and the eye patch.
Yeah, I had eye surgery.
So, I don't talk about
this all the time actually
but I'm actually visually impaired.
- Oh?
- Yeah, I can't see out of my right eye.
So, and I had eye surgery to sort of just
correct some issues and, you
know, I had to wear the patch.
- Yeah, no, I had a LASIK done,
like right after I won idol
was the first thing I did for
myself that like, cost money.
And I was like almost blind.
Like, I couldn't see at all.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I was like the best
candidate, because I was so,
they were like, your eyesight is so bad,
you're a perfect candidate.
- You're like, we need to do this.
- But I had to wear like
a Hannibal Lecter mask.
I don't, I look crazy.
They had like this thing,
cause you couldn't touch your
in your sleep. It was weird.
- You can't, yeah. I just had
to wear that for like a week.
It was a minimally invasive surgery.
I've had like surgeries
that have were much worse.
So, thankfully I just had to wear that
for like a week and then I was fine.
- Yeah. Okay. Well I'm glad you're good.
- Thank you.
- I thought you pulled
up the pirate very well.
- I mean, I try honey. I try.